So apparently, a lot of parents are upset with this JoJo Siwa.
You didn't know she was a little girl on the show Dance Mom?
For a long time, she was this, like,
child star. She had this line of bows for little girls.
She had all this colorful stuff.
And now she's getting older,
and, like a lot of,
you know, child celebrities,
they have this rebrand when they become adults, where they become edgy
and, you know,
she has different songs that have, like,
edgy music videos, and she, like, drinks. Anyway,
a lot of parents are upset with her.
They're saying, like,
my children look up to you.
Like, you are a role model.
You're supposed to be a role model for these kids.
When I was growing up,
the big thing was Miley Cyrus.
I remember the same kind of thing happening where she got older.
People were like,
oh, my goodness,
this is horrible.
What a horrible example.
But I was like,
I don't care. She's not my role model.
She's just, like, this person on TV.
And I like her songs.
And that's as deep as it goes,
and that's as deep as it should go for anybody with a celebrity,
but especially,
especially for a child.
Say what you will about her,
about how cringy these celebrities are and how you don't like them
and how they're immoral and all that,
I probably agree with you.
But you should not be upset with Them
for being bad role models for your children?
Because they should not be role models for your children.
Children's role models should be people they know in real life.
This idea of worshipping celebrities so much
that we become personally offended
when they lead us astray
or lead our children astray is ridiculous.
Get your children off of TikTok.
They should know nothing about JoJo Siwa's personal life.
They should not care because you should be their role model.
You should be the one that they look to for guidance
for what is wrong and what is right.
You are the one who is supposed to be doing that.
If children are becoming confused,
if they are being LED astray,
it isn't the fault of some random person on TikTok.
It is the fault of parents.
Parents need to be stronger.
Parents need to take charge of their children's lives
far more than they do right now.